d'habitude quand alexandre descend dans
le sud de la france à mandelieu c'est
pour passer du bon temps en famille
aujourd'hui avec ses proches sa femme et
son fils il ne reconnaît plus la
résidence où il venait passer ses
vacances
le voyage est douloureux
sa mère et son beau père s'était
installée ici il y a huit ans pour
démarrer une nouvelle vie au soleil
leur rêve s'est achevée samedi dernier
lors des inondations qui ont touché le
département
les eaux ont submergé le parking de
l'immeuble n'a plus rien la voiture
allait mal
ils ont mis le truc dessus la voiture en
rester là
ils sont descendus il y avait il y avait
apparemment à 10 15 cm d'eau et en 10
secondes
voilà on dise monde s'est monté à 4 m
[Musique]
la bague et elle est arrivée et bas et
déjà emporté dans le fond et puis l'ol
et monte monte il n'y a pas d'issue donc
après
[Musique]
surtout la mort atroce ce qu'ils ont dit
avoir cessé car en fait j'ai repensé de
mourir envoyé un de pas voir l'issue de
rien c'est voilà c'est fait remporter
comme ça par le courant et ne pas
pouvoir s'en échapper ça doit être ça
doit être horrible comme dans le parking
de cette résidence
quatre personnes ont perdu la vie en
tentant de sauver leur voiture l'orage a
laissé place au beau temps difficile de
réaliser ce qui a bien pu se passer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la piscine
la loi elle est vraiment noir de chez
noir
là y'a plus là il faut la vider la
[Musique]
caisse que c'était vraiment aller
toujours sourire quand le temps des
larmes sera passée viendra celui des
questions comment un tel drame at-il pu
arriver
etait-il possible de l'éviter
samedi dernier il est un peu plus de 20h
à mandelieu la pluie commence à tomber
charlie lambert policier municipal est
en patrouille dans la ville
surpris par la montée rapide des eaux
lui et son collègue décide de filmer
leurs interventions
[Applaudissements]
elle a compris que ça commence à devenir
cambre et bon ben on s'est arrêtés puis
on a vu des voitures au milieu on était
à porter secours tout de suite quoi les
voitures commençaient à flotter un donc
les gens commençaient à voir les les
deux logements au niveau des portières
sam en terre très rapidement du balcon
d'un immeuble des riverains filmé
l'intervention
on y voit charlie lambert évacuer des
passagers de leur véhicule
écoutez ça s'est passé ici la justice''
dit plusieurs véhicules qui étaient
carrément noyer
mais vous savez ils attendaient dans
leurs véhicules je sais pas pourquoi il
restait un petit peu immobile il avait
l'air un peu étonné même qu'on leur
demande de sortir pour eux je sais pas
si je pense pas qu'ils avaient pris
conscience de la situation à cause des
inondations
certains habitants se retrouveront
piégés dans leurs voitures
[Musique]
des véhicules enchevêtrés les uns sur
les autres
des rues envahies par la boue
ici une route bloquée par un glissement
de terrain charlie lambert arrive dans
la résidence du cap vert les pompiers
tentent d'évacuer l'eau qui a envahi les
parkings la rue beaucoup de de dégâts
énormément de dégâts et beaucoup de de
malheur puisque également bien les
pompiers ont découvert des décors ici
aussi dans les sous sols
[Applaudissements]
c'était pour nous l'apocalypse voyant
tout ça on s'est posé des questions
savons comment c'était possible en fête
toute la nuit
charlie lambert reste stupéfait devant
l'ampleur de la catastrophe
lorsque nous arrivons pour la première
fois dans la résidence le riu ce petit
cours d'eau qui longe les bâtiments a
retrouvé son lit
[Musique]
les habitants que nous croisons sont
encore marqués par les ravages qu'il a
entraîné ses des parkings de son
[Musique]
tous les appartements situés en
rez-de-chaussée ont été détruits
[Musique]
vous évitez la résidence depuis
longtemps je suis tout rebâtir ma mère
acheté sur plan les habitants de la
résidence ont été surpris par la
rapidité de la montée des eaux
voilà j'ai récupéré sa chérie samedi
soir dominique et son mari patrick un
couple de retraités étaient dans leur
salon quand l'eau est arrivé voilà ça
c'est notre canapé en dessous la machine
à laver et la halle et plein de la
plaine de dos au bout j'en sais rien
tout est dégueulasse on venait de finir
de dîner je voulais finir ma vaisselle
voyez l'on est arrivé en fait par le
fond par l'autre jardin et c'est arrivé
comme ça ça a tourné comme ça
mais je pense en fait que il ya beaucoup
d'eau qui est arrivée par ce côté là
vraiment c'est un torrent le couple n'a
pas tout de suite mesuré la gravité de
la situation
quelqu'un nous a appelés à l'interphone
pour ne dire que les parkings commencé à
être inondées
[Musique]
cherchez la maison barry est allé voir
il est descendu et quand il est arrivé
au niveau du sous-sol pour ouvrir la
porte du parking il a vu qu'avec l'outil
arrivait donc il va refermer leurs
commentaires
une décision qui l'a sauvé le couple a
quitté son appartement et trouvé refuge
chez des voisins au deuxième étage
ginette denis leurs voisines
elle est descendue dans le parking elle
a réussi à sortir sa voiture dans la
résidence mettre à l'abri son véhicule
en cas d'orage c'est presque devenu une
habitude pour certains habitants via
veria santo dans les garages
il ya une explosion d'un côté et une
vague c'est arrivé aussi et je suis
passé à travers la vague on est passé à
prince voiture on descend toujours quand
il ya tant il ya de l'orage pour sortir
nos voitures on le fait depuis dix ans à
chaque année beaucoup ont pensé qu'il
s'agissait ce soir là d'un orage
ordinaire comme il y en a souvent cette
saison ils n'ont pas imaginer qu'avec
ces pluies
le débit du riou le cours d'eau juste à
côté de la résidence serait cinq fois
plus important sur mon téléphone j'ai
une alerte orange c'est tout c'est tout
ce que j'ai eu
une alerte orange comme celle-là en
provenance d'un site internet spécialisé
dans la météo
ginette denis en a déjà reçu quelques
unes elle n'y prête plus vraiment
attention
la mairie ne prévient les habitants
qu'en cas d' alerte rouge émise par
météo france ce n'était pas le cas ce
soir là les habitants ont-ils été
informés des dangers que pouvait
représenter ces parkings lors d'orages
violents
neuf cent mille images henri leroy et le
maire de mandelieu ce lundi soir il a
réuni ses équipes pour traiter les
dernières urgence
on a aujourd'hui 20 morts dans le
département
c'est quand même énorme
derrière lui une carte elle rappelle
qu'une grande partie de la ville est en
zone inondable
ici en rouge et en bleu
toutes les résidences le lavandin et le
cap vert c'est là et donc c'est en jaune
blanc pour protéger sa ville le maire
explique que des travaux ont été
entrepris pour 17 millions d'euros
il affirme avoir informé les habitants
des risques liés aux inondations
est ce que les habitants sont ainsi
sensibilisés oui vous savez on a ce
qu'on appelle un dicrim document
d'information communal sur les risques
majeurs qui ont été distribués à chaque
citoyen ça raconte toutes les mesures à
prendre en cas de problématique des
événements majeurs
je vous en aux phrases si vous voulez
puisque vous êtes à mandelieu
voilà cette plaquette nous l'avons fêté
au chapitre inondations il est
recommandé de signaler sa présence pour
être repérés par les secours de ne pas
revenir sur ses pas ou encore de gagner
les hauteurs de la ville
aucune information sur les dangers liés
au parking pour henri leroy les raisons
du drame survenu sur sa commune sont à
chercher du côté des habitants les gens
sont descendus dans les parkings du sous
sol s'il n'était pas descendu il n'y
aurait pas eu de mort tous les gens qui
sont descendus ils savaient qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas décembre ils le savaient
fort bien mais vous savez on oublie et
puis ça va pas m'arriver à moi
des habitants qui auraient manqué de
discernement
n'y at-il vraiment aucune autre
explication
[Musique]
ce qui saute aux yeux quand on se
promène sur la côte c'est la densité des
constructions mandelieu n'échappe pas à
la règle
pour mieux s'en rendre compte il suffit
de comparer deux cartes de la commune
voici mandelieu en 1965 quelques zones
construites et surtout beaucoup de
champs mais au fil des ans le béton a
envahi les espaces verts
quarante ans plus tard cette frénésie
immobilière est loin d'être terminée
dans la ville voici l'une des dernières
réalisations sorti de terre il ya tout
juste un an
la résidence des quatre saisons le
terrain est classé en zone blanche aucun
risque d'inondation et pourtant
l'immeuble est à seulement vingt mètres
du riou de largentière qui a débordé
samedi dernier c'est ici que pascal et
alexia honte acheter un appartement
jusqu alors leur petit paradis mais
samedi soir
pascal a bien failli y laisser la vie
dans tout le département les mêmes
images sur ces vidéos filmées par les
habitants des pluies diluviennes qui
transforme les rues en torrents de boue
pascal et à quelques mètres de son
domicile
lui aussi a sorti sa voiture du garage
pour la mettre à l'abri mais sur le
chemin du retour ils se retrouvent
piégés au milieu de la route
accroché à ce panneau quand on voit
comme ça fonce dos et c'est ça va mais
et imaginez un torrent qui vient de qui
vient du pont là haut au feu rouge avec
avec beaucoup de détritus qui arrive
j'ai pu me faufiler jusqu'à ce panneau
là et c'est de là où je me sentais plus
proche c'est là où j'ai commencé à
gueuler en disant à l'aide à l'aide à
l'aide
alexia sa femme est à seulement quelques
mètres de lui
elles tentent de lui porter secours fait
on a été pas lui qui dit un bon tiens
bon tiens bon et il a lâché j'ai glissé
sur le sur les ventes
et je me suis retrouvé ici au deuxième
panneau mon alliance s'est prise dans le
boulon c'est là où l'alliance m'a sauvé
c'est là où c'est symbolique c'est parce
qu'elle en est sûr il ne doit sa survie
qu'à cet instant là l'instant où son
alliance a arrêté sa course
ça m'a permis de me retourner et de
pouvoir être sûr e sur le dos mais
couché j'ai compris j'ai continué là
j'ai continué de dériver déjà accroché
ce chêne et non pour vous donner une
idée gt gt accroché mao et j'avais de
longer nous un peu près finalement parce
qu'elle parvient à atteindre le sommet
de la colline
alexia regagné la résidence elle est
sans nouvelles de lui
ce sont des voisins prévenu par pascal
qui vont la rassurer les voisins qui
étaient sur notre terrasse mon hurler
parce qu'à vidéo t'inquiète pas il
revient
comme beaucoup d'habitants de mandelieu
pascal ce soir-là a risqué sa vie pour
sauver sa voiture elle lui est
indispensable
le souci c'est les assurances pourquoi
pourquoi on va sauver nos voitures parce
qu'il ya trois mois de délai ou minimum
on peut pas on peut parfois aller
travailler en s'installant ici pascal et
alexia n'aurais jamais imaginé vivre un
tel cauchemar alors le risque
d'inondations at-il été sous-estimé le
terrain n'est pas classé dans une zone à
risque
pourtant les garages de la résidence ont
tous été inondées pascal ne semble pas
surpris on était passé quelques fois la
mairie justement pour savoir où c'est
qu'on mettait les pieds
et si c'était une honda votre oppression
seco et mandelieu c'est une zone
sinistrée il ya de l'autre partout à
chaque fois on est finalement conscient
on est à côté d'une rivière français on
sait que quoi qu'il en soit au moins une
fois tous les 50 ans il y aura une race
rassemblement des événements entre des
habitants conscients des risques sur ce
projet immobilier
le promoteur l'était aussi nous sommes
allés à sa rencontre
son siège est à paris bonjour richard
molinier richard molinier et le patron
du groupe
il nous explique avoir pris en compte la
présence de ce cours d'eau tout près de
l'immeuble
or pour la côte du terrain naturel
l'immeuble a été surélevé d'un mètre il
est un maître complémentaire de
garde-corps en béton plein ce qui
permettait d'avoir une ceinture de
protection de l'immeuble de 2 m par
rapport à la cote du terrain naturel
sachant que le rio se situe encore en
contrebas des 3,4 m construire sur des
zones sensibles
selon ce promoteur difficile de faire
autrement dans cette région on a une
vraie carence en termes de nombre de
logements si la région il ya une vraie
pression de la population site pour se
loger
on est sur des on est sur un territoire
où on est
700 habitants kilomètres carrés en terme
d'intensité donc on est sur un
territoire très dense on est sur un
territoire très contraint sur le plan
géographique
donc on peut construire principalement
sur la zone du littoral 85% des
habitants de paca à 8 sur une zone qui
fait moins de 10 kilomètres entre la mer
et la montagne
pas suffisamment de place et beaucoup de
demandes
cette pression ressentie par les
promoteurs pestel également sur les
municipalités
henri leroy le maire de mandelieu s'en
défend il explique se sentir parfois
contraints de délivrer des permis de
construire
quand vous refuser un permis de
construire alors que les droits
permettent la délivrance du permis
vous êtes attaqués aussi en justice vous
êtes responsable et sachez le bien que
le tribunal peut vous obliger à délivrer
effectivement les droits acquis des
citoyens reste une question
cette urbanisation intensive à graves
tels les dégâts causés par les pluies
torrentielles
à quelques kilomètres de mandelieu de
l'autre côté de l'aéroport
l'entrée de cannes
nous avons rendez vous avec denis perry
mon militants écologistes ils habitent
la région depuis toujours
samedi dernier son magasin de meubles a
été inondée j'ai vu le courant qui
défilait à 7 8 10 km heure en allant de
demandes de lieux vers l'au-delà vers
cannes et qui tournait dans la rue ici
emportant toutes les voitures qui
étaient en travers denis a voulu nous
montrer qu'elles sont selon lui les
conséquences de cette expansion urbaine
nous allons découvrir en sa compagnie à
quel point le visage de sa commune a
changé
[Musique]
ici toute cette partie là c'était une
immense prairie ou qui allaient jusqu'à
mandelieu et qui a été un bâti donc là
il ya des écoles céline elle derrière il
ya le collège des mûriers toutes les
recouverts de béton ou presque il ya
quelques petites zones de gazon et donc
l'eau ne s'infiltre plus dans dans le
sol les pluies ne pénètrent plus les
sols désormais en béton elle reste en
surface et ne peuvent plus être évacués
voilà là vous avez donc la meilleure
c'est un des ruisseaux qui régale à la
bocca ce ruisseau est aujourd'hui devenu
ce qu'on appelle un vallon coincé entre
des parois de béton le ruisseau l'allée
du mur qui est là n'existait pas c'est
un autre mur à celui là donc la largeur
était plus grande on a construit dessus
et c'était de la terre alors l origine
et sur le côté vous aviez des pierres
qui étaient jointes les sentiments ce
qui fait que quand l'eau monte à
s'impliquer dans les jardins parce que
si ce n'était que des petites maisons à
un étage avec desjardins devant et
derrière lots donc s'infiltre dans les
jardins sans proposer de dégâts et le
lamer secuneo niveau actuel rend dans
l'inondation 100-200 débordé et
maintenant il ya ce qui peut passer et
le reste bas ça déborde
en cas de pluie torrentielle ces ballons
sont le seul moyen d'évacuer l'eau en
excès leur entretien est cruciale ce
jour là deux techniciens ont été
dépêchés par la ville pour les contrôler
des ballons comme celui là la ville en
est quadrillée 180 km de cours d'eau
certains à ciel ouvert d'autres
invisible sous les bâtiments un circuit
à contrôler pour éviter les embâcles des
bouchons formé par des débris de toutes
sortes comme ce bloc de béton qui
barrent le canal c'est le mur people oui
puisqu'il a aujourd'hui une source dans
bach dit les branchements venir se
mettre sur le bloc devons nous
développer complètement l'écoulement
[Musique]
si les vallons se bouchent l'eau déborde
ils n'ont de l'est parking situé en
sous-sol et dévale dans les rues de la
ville les pluies de samedi soir était
trop importante les ruisseaux et les
rivières ont quitté leur nid
voilà donc là vous avez la rivière la
frayère qui est un tout petit cours
d'eau et qui a pris des proportions
énormes caen samedi soir sous la
violence des flots plusieurs voitures
ont été emportées
samedi soir c'était le torrent n'amorce
qui n'a eu trois morts dans la prière
donc c'est pas on sait pas une rigolade
au cours de l'interview le directeur
général des services de la ville de
cannes vient à notre rencontre lui aussi
souligner le comportement des habitants
durant cette catastrophe
pourquoi suis-je pas comme une part de
responsabilité comme un bon père non je
ne vois pas en quoi
voilà j'ai en face à face à ces
événements là qui parfois de la
disparition que l'on déplore c'est
peut-être ce qu'il y ait parfois des
comportements quand voilà les
comportements personnels individuel
quand il ya un risque
vous n'avez pas courir le risque de ne
pas courir le risque de prendre votre
voiture conclut avait pas courir le
risque de descendre dans votre local
dans vos garages en sous sol pour
pouvoir aller chercher je ne sais quoi
des habitants qui se mettraient
eux-mêmes en danger mais sont ils
correctement alerté en cas d'inondation
imminente
à côté d'antibes la commune de biot
elles aussi touchées par la catastrophe
samedi dernier trois personnes sont
décédées dans cette ville une des
solutions trouvées par les élus locaux
pour avertir la population des systèmes
d' alerte
yann pastore est le responsable des
équipements de la commune
il veille sur les sirènes qui
préviennent les habitants en cas
d'inondation
[Musique]
on est soit dans le secteur le plus
touché par la par l'inondation sirène et
là où elles sont récentes bien à quatre
qui sont répartis sur le territoire
communal
c'est système habituel c'est ce que les
communes utilisent ce type de système
par déclenchement par ligne téléphonique
sur un simple appel téléphonique
le maire ou celui qui dirige les
opérations de secours peut déclencher
les sirènes
pourtant samedi dernier malgré les
fortes précipitations les sirènes de
biot sont restées muettes
[Musique]
yann pasteures et a accepté de nous
révéler la raison de ce silence
en ce gars là ouais mais vous mais ce
n'est pas tout le temps parce que j'ai
vécu ce france d'accord l'explication se
trouve au bout de ce chemin dans ce
local
voilà le central téléphonique à
l'intérieur des appareils des câbles une
installation électrique la plupart des
collections avec connexion téléphonique
de biot transitent par ici c'est ici
qu'arrivent le coup de téléphone qui
déclenche les sirènes mais le week-end
dernier le local s'est retrouvée inondée
hors service on voit la hauteur d'eau ou
à les dépôts sont étrangement
l'opérateur qui a installé la centrale
téléphonique dans les années 70 a choisi
de l'implanter au bord de cette rivière
la brague aujourd'hui en zone inondable
ça
60 et pu être installé six très vague
c'est une bonne question le technicien
est embarrassée car à biot
le problème est connu depuis 2011 on a
découvert en fait cette faiblesse du
réseau téléphonique ya pas très
longtemps
lors de la dernière inondation qui était
moins importante que celle ci en quatre
ans il n'y ait pas eu plus de mes
actions
c'est vrai qu'on n'y a jamais imaginé
avoir un phénomène de ce type là est
aussi précoce depuis quatre ans que fait
la municipalité confrontés à nos
questions
la mairie de biot serait sur le point de
régler la situation
oui bonjour je suis bien la mairie de
biot
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
concrètement pour que cette centrale ne
soit plus jamais inondées comme ça a été
le cas qu'est ce que vous attendez
[Musique]
oui simplement pour l'éloigner de la
plupart des communes attendent
l'alertent rouge de météo france pour
prévenir la population du danger dans le
département voisin une commune s'est
dotée d'un système de surveillance météo
beaucoup plus précis et surtout à l'abri
des inondations grâce à un logiciel qui
lui permet de réagir en temps réel
vincent maurice lemaire scrute
l'évolution de la météo sur sa commune
parce qu'on estime soner oui si nous
sommes dans la salle qui s'appelle pc
crise on est dans une situation où on a
une alerte orange il pleut sur la
commune et donc on allume ses
ordinateurs
nous suivons l'évolution de la carte du
territoire avec les masses pluvieuse
à sainte-maxime grâce à ce système le
maire et ses équipes peuvent réagir au
risque d'inondation dès que les
précipitations atteignent un seuil qu'il
juge critique et même si météo france
n'a émis qu'une alerte orange
l'équipe municipale envoient des
messages de mise en garde aux riverains
comme celui-ci donc épisode pluvieux et
venteux important jusqu'au 25 12 19
heures risque de débordement des cours
d'eau
et après à partir d'une plateforme
nationale on envoie le sms
le message était acheminée en moins
d'une minute et vincent morisse peut
être aussi précis qu'il le souhaite
on va dire aux gens montés dans les
étages vous réfugiez par exemple alors
comment vous décidez justement du
message qui va être écrit on s'adapte à
la situation dans laquelle on est il n'y
a pas de message à l'avance pré écrit ce
dispositif coûte 5000 euros par an à la
mairie il est gratuit pour les habitants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jeannette et jean-claude cambier compte
beaucoup sur ses méthodes d' alerte pour
échapper à la montée des eaux
installée à sainte maxime depuis onze
ans le couple a déjà été inondés quatre
fois tout a explosé
des photos pour ne pas regarder j'ai
fait on n'a plus envie de re voir
l'année dernière l'eau a une nouvelle
fois envahi la maison grâce au système
d' alerte
ils ont pu quitter les lieux pour se
mettre à l'abri
mais c'est évident que les sms ont
forcément une efficacité
cette année contrairement aux habitants
des alpes-maritimes ceux de sainte
maxime n'ont pas subi d'inondations
mais tous savent qu'ils ne devront
jamais relâché leur vigilance
[Musique]